Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Telas.
Pañuelo.
Pañal.
Velo, venda, barbijo, antifaz.
Camiseta, calzoncillo, media.
Camisón, corpiño, bombacha.
Sábanas. Toallas.
Remera, pantalón, camisa.
Bufanda, capucha, alpargata.
Vestido, tapado.
Sotana, burka, talit.
Forro, funda, curita.
Servilleta, cortina,
repasador, mantel, mantilla.
Lona, reposera, toldo.
Paraguas, paracaídas.
Velas de barco. Redes de pesca.
Banderines. Banderas.
Telas para vivir.
¿Quién desafía el hecho de pasar
un día en la vida sin tocar una tela?
Ni de día, ni de noche.
Llegamos al mundo y nos envuelven
en un pañal blanco, suave, limpio.
Es el mejor lugar para llegar.
Y ¿para morir?
Como momias
nos seguimos envolviendo en telas.
Sean vendas o sean mortajas.
¿Por qué las telas?
Habiendo tantos materiales que inventó
el ser humano, ¿nada la reemplaza?
Del cultivo o del animal,
el ser humano sacó la fibra
para hacer un hilo
y comenzar a tramar historias.
La tela es un material único.
Es suave, es resistente,
es amigo del cuerpo,
es térmico, es lavable.
¿A cuántas personas conocen sin ropa?
Ojalá que a muchas.
(Risas)
Desnudos, digo, ¿eh?
¿A cuántos?
La ropa es nuestra piel social.
¿Qué pasaría si me saco la ropa
acá, ahora?
(Silbidos)
Hacemos un pacto entre nosotros
con la ropa como piel,
que rara vez nos animamos a romper.
Tenemos que acudir a ciertas sustancias
para poder animarnos
a veces a sacarnos la ropa.
La ropa es nuestra piel social,
es nuestra cáscara,
es nuestros pelos, y son nuestras plumas.
Con la ropa nos construimos
en nuestras identidades.
Con la ropa nos diferenciamos.
Con la ropa nos seducimos.
Con la ropa nos uniformamos
en roles, en oficios, y en creencias.
Entre sábanas hacemos el amor.
Entre telas construimos
nuestras familias.
Y todos los días, todas las noches,
volvemos a nuestra cuna de tela,
nuestra cama.
¿Siempre fue así la tela, tan importante?
Siempre. Porque el textil es prehistórico.
La raza humana aprendió a tejer
antes que a escribir.
Y tejiendo, aprendió mucho más.
Tejiendo aprendimos a gestionar
y a organizar materiales.
Tejiendo aprendimos a crear,
a mezclar mundos materiales
con mundos espirituales.
Y tejiendo, también nos construimos
en nuestras metáforas.
Hay un cordón que me trae al mundo,
que es el cordón umbilical.
Hay un tejido que es mi piel,
que es un tejido conectado.
Y nosotros somos una gran trama social.
En este momento
un textil se está cargando de mí.
De mi transpiración, de mis olores,
de mí, de mi cuerpo.
Y a Uds. les está pasando lo mismo.
Y más tarde mis textiles se van a cargar
con el perfume de mis amores.
Ojalá. Ojalá que les pase lo mismo.
¿Qué anida el textil?
¿Qué tiene en esos recovecos?
¿Qué guarda además
de polvo, células, ADN?
Si miramos un textil a la lupa
veremos una sucesión increíble
de puntos, organizadísimos,
que en una secuencia de abrazos
se relacionan unos con otros,
como en una especie de telar,
componiendo ese todo textil.
¿Y si somos una trama?
Ahora, acá, ¿a ver?
Uds. ¿cómo se podrían relacionar?
Podría ser por las manos, por los brazos.
A ver, probá.
¡Bien!
En un momento hacían algo
como una especie de ola.
Me gustaría que hagan un telar...
Sigan, por favor. Todos.
Y ¿sabes qué?
Como no los veo,
levanten las manos, a ver.
Ahí va. Allá también, a ver, un telar.
¡Eso!
A ver si se animan,
si yo hago flamear esta bandera humana.
¡Va!
Tiene que flamear hasta el fondo.
¡Eso!
Somos una trama humana viva.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)